my work now is helping people to
optimize performance get a good
relationship with themselves finding a
peace happiness confidence professor
steve peters he's a world leading
psychiatrist arguably one of the most
famous renowned and important of our
time
you will come out the other side much
better people do recover from broken
relationships people don't know what the
next relationship will be not everybody
is the same
what tends to happen is people either
don't recognize they're getting stressed
and it becomes chronic and they've got
these behaviors which are damaging to
them as people think stress is where
we're wringing our hands and panicking
and that's not really true stress comes
in all different forms and often isn't
recognized
even for people in a much more serious
situation where they become suicidal you
can tell them with honesty there is
always a future and things do change and
feelings do move
and we have to accept that reality we
cannot know everything about the person
we're with and if our chimps which are
panicky a bit and want guarantees and
what then we're going down the wrong
path and we have to tell our chimp you
can't do this
[Music]
professor steve peters he's a world
leading psychiatrist arguably one of the
most famous renowned and important of
our time he's also a doctor and a hugely
successful author
some of you most of you will know him
from his best-selling book the chimp
paradox which has sold millions of
copies worldwide and that's a book that
actually saved the lives of some people
very close to me he's worked with elite
level athletes including steven gerrard
and the england football team and ronnie
o'sullivan gold medal olympians like sir
chris hoy and victoria pendleton as well
as business leaders and ceos and he
helps them overcome what he calls mental
dysfunction he's helped them optimize
for performance and he's really helped
them get out of their own way and in
many respects in life we're all in our
own way steve's invented this
groundbreaking concept called the chimp
model and it focuses on how there's
these kind of three parts to our brain
the first part is called the chimp which
is our sort of desire to be impulsive
and irrational and emotional and short
term the second part is what he calls
the human and you'll hear him talk about
this which is logical and rational and
thinks in terms of facts and thinks
things through in the long term and the
third part is what he calls the computer
which is our set of core values and
beliefs
steve's work focuses on how we can
manage and control the interaction
between these three parts of our brain
and we all have these three compartments
within our brains and if you can
understand them if you can understand
these three elements it gives you
greater power to utilize them
to be happy successful however you
define it and to live a much more
fulfilled life
man this episode gave me so many
personal epiphanies so many sort of
penny drop moments and so many personal
realizations it's one of the podcasts
that i i know i'll reflect on going
forward and i know for sure
will change my life forever so this is
one where i implore you to listen to the
entire conversation because i think it
will change your life too so without
further ado sorry that was a very long
intro i'm stephen bartlett and this is
the direva ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
professor steve peters thank you for for
joining me today i've been a big fan of
your work as has a lot of people close
to me in my life for a long long period
of time um where i wanted to start with
you is with a question which is
how do you define yourself
professionally and i've read you know
i've read about the diverse amount of
work you've done across multiple sectors
with sports stars with leaders with
with the nhs with the the fire service
with um you know a broad spectrum of
people but what is the sort of basis of
your work and how do you define what you
do okay well thanks for inviting me
coming from medical background i define
myself as a doctor who is specialized in
the mental health
area of medicine
and then moved a little bit sideways
into just mentoring and helping people
to gain understanding and insights into
the way that their mind functions
and then applying that into whatever
they take me so effectively i'm an
educator um with a medical basis but i
still have patients i would treat but
the generally my work now is helping
people to optimize performance or get a
good relationship with themselves
um finding a piece the kind of things
people want happiness confidence or even
things like high performing teams so a
vast spectrum but the basis of all of
this is do you understand what's going
on inside your head to understand
yourself
and what's the because
some people are easily confused between
psychiatry and psychology what's the
distinction as you see it well the
distinction is that psychologists are
experts in usually a specific area
within psychology so educational
psychologists would look at how we
educate children and and adults and how
they learn best whereas you might get a
clinical psychologist or work with
someone who's got maybe depressive
illness and look at the cognitive
aspects of that the way we think and
behave um adult
psychiatry is a medical doctor so we
tend to treat mental illness as opposed
to dysfunction
so mental illness is where we know that
the in simplistic terms the brain isn't
functioning well something is going
wrong often it's transmitter systems so
we treat them
when we might find as a psychiatrist
that it's dysfunction so then we would
do overlap work with what psychologists
would do right got you
um you
your book the chimp paradox really
focused on psychological dysfunction yes
um and was that born out of your that
was born out of your work in psychiatry
yes i mean when i was in the nhs as a
consultant for many years people come to
the door who had mental illness which
then we would treat and support and help
and get them on their feet
but also a significant number of people
came through the door who didn't need
treatment per se they they had the mind
was fully functional and operating well
they didn't know how to operate it so
because they didn't operate well with
the mind it was creating a lot of
emotional distress
and so they would present as if it were
an illness but in my my book it wasn't
an illness so i worked with that
dysfunction and out of that work was
born the neuroscience basis of the the
chimp model to say look let's have a
look at the brain and see what is the
brain actually doing and how did it
develop and how can we apply that to you
today
i want to go down those two paths so i
want to go down the mental health path
and then also the mental dysfunction
path so if we start with the mental
health path
um there's this kind of prevailing
narrative in culture at the moment that
mental health disorders are on the
increase and that people are getting
more and more depressed and more and
more anxious um in your view is that is
that accurate
this is a complex topic and the answer
would be that we're more aware of it
it's probably reported more but um
mental illness per se
will can sometimes be born out of mental
dysfunction so if we get stressed in our
work saying we don't manage it well or
in relationships and we don't manage
that well then we know that given time
for many individuals the
neurotransmitters in the brain start to
malfunction right so we can create
ineffectively an illness by not managing
the mind well
alternatively it can spontaneously
malfunction so people can have a great
life look after themselves yet still
suddenly go into a clinical depression
because the system has failed much like
say a thyroid might fail they haven't
done anything wrong it's just the system
has failed
and is the the changing world we live in
the more sort of digitalized world where
i don't know our lives are being i guess
more optimized for i guess productivity
and
um
optimized against things like exercise
for example you know i can order my
lunch by clicking a button now and i can
meet dates just by swiping on my phone
um is it your belief that that changed
world a more digital world more social
media-centric world the world we live in
today is more conducive with mental
illness
i think again after talking broad terms
everybody's unique which means that
somebody will find that really
advantageous to just press a button and
the lunch arrives and they don't need
that people interaction we're all on a
spectrum the vast majority of us are
built to interact we are gregarious by
nature and we like people around us and
we like to have relationships so clearly
if somebody's isolated in an office or
working from home then they will miss
that aspect so if they don't actually
compensate in some way which satisfies
their need for this interaction then
it's likely they will start to become
distressed so in that sense i think
because most of us are gregarious and
we're more and more isolated
if we don't make steps to change that
round it's likely people will find they
get more stressed and more anxiety will
appear and more clinical depression may
appear yeah i asked that question just
because i'm i'm i'm unsure as you said
at the start of your answer whether it's
just because of awareness has increased
around mental illness or if um the world
we live in now is make is not uh meeting
us i guess our fundamental human needs i
think it's a bit of everything and i
think therefore researchers will look at
the idea that for example social media
has a massive input which it wasn't
there so we go back 20 years and there
wasn't social media as such and now it's
become very prominent in many people's
lives and we know that most of us don't
respond well to criticism and and if
it's public criticism then we really
don't respond well so that can be an
extremely destructive force on people
however if people use social media
appropriately and and are able to block
out any of these negative comments that
people make then they'll probably find
it an advantageous thing to actually
communicate with friends and family so
again it's it's not so much what's
happening in society it's how we
interact with it and learn what works
for us as individuals so it's stopping
and getting time to think what are my
needs and a lot of people don't really
know that you have to discover them and
then how do i put them in place that
work for me
and on that point of needs as it relates
to sort of mental
good mental health um are you able to
point at some fundamental things that we
all
need
to have um or things that are most
conducive tip generally broadly with
good mental health
yeah so if you came to me and you said
right can we just do like a bit of a
psychological profile let me have a look
at my life and see how i'm going then
often people are not what we call great
historians they don't give me
information i've got to sort of pull the
information out with appropriate
questions
and the rare is yes i would touch on so
first of all i would
certainly look at the relationship you
have with yourself what's your own
self-image self-worth
self-confidence i would like to see
where you stand in those areas because
we start with you if if someone's in a
good place then it's likely they'll cope
with the world but if someone's not in a
good place with themself and within
themselves then it's unlikely they'll
cope with the world because your
starting point is not good
and when i've done that then we'll look
at things like relationships so you want
to see what kind of relationships do you
particularly need or want at this point
in your life and what kind of
relationships have you got and are you
maximizing them are they dysfunctional
you know is it to do with the
communication between you we look at
communication
but apart from that i'll go to
fundamental drives
you know do you recognize the drives you
have and the obvious ones are eating
drives um the drive for sex for security
for territory we'll look at how you
apply those because these are drives
that all of us have to greater or less
extend but sometimes it's hidden drives
so one of the ones is a purpose
uh recognition
you know a feeling of value
in what you do or who you are so these
are drives we all have but often they
get neglected because people don't
recognize them and once you actually
point them out and you say well how are
you going to fulfill these then we can
work on what works for you so i don't
tell people i don't have like a recipe
book i can't do that
i know other people can i can't what i
like to do is work with you as a team
and you say to me this is what my needs
are i challenge that to try and make
sure it's really clear
and then we'll look at what you think
will work for you maybe i'll come up
with ideas and suggestions or challenge
beliefs you've got
and then we work together to say what
are your outcome objectives what do you
want to achieve in the next three months
six months 12 months
and look what's realistic so it's it's
quite a detailed
almost like an mot on the person's mind
make sure everything's up and
functioning
two things i was super intrigued there
by is that the idea of self-image and
what that really really means um because
i've heard the term of you know
self-image i guess that's how you see
yourself
um insecurities and all or is
insecurities uh impact how you see
yourself well this is where
20 something years ago now uh in the
early 90s it struck me as a younger
doctor that
um
the mind isn't one entity working so
when i ask people about self-image i'm
now going to split the mind a bit and
say what is the self-image that you feel
you would like to have
and that you are aiming to to present to
the world and what's the genetic
self-image that your mind is giving you
and the mind interpreting hence i
started saying you have this circuitry
which is rational logical looking at the
facts and you have a circuitry which is
emotionally based so it's not logic and
emotion it's logically based with
emotion and it's emotion based with
logic
and we don't control that so if i try
and that's detail i should listen to
that one again
is
what i'm saying is we have control over
the circuitry which i call the human
circuits and your self-image then might
be that i'm a compassionate guy that i'm
a trustworthy person that i always give
100 this is what your self-image could
be when i discuss
with you and your circuits are
responding however
if you've moved the blood supply and
oxygen uptake into what i'm calling the
chimp circuits circuits which are quite
primitive but think you don't have any
control over that so they will generate
thinking and the chimp circus may give a
very different answer
because they're much more likely to be
emotionally say how you feel about
yourself rather than reality
so the feeling could be the reality but
it's it's likely not to be
so we get two images from two different
circuits and what is informing the champ
right so the chimp when it starts off in
life this is going heavy neuroscience as
we develop in the fetus the the chimp
circuitry which is the orbiter frontal
cortex heads it up this is a part of our
brain just above our eyes starts to
think but it thinks in an emotional way
so it it reacts to things it doesn't
think ahead with consequence it reacts
impulsively and it relies on the center
of the brain the rest of the limbic
system it's part of the limbic
uh to actually store this our
experiences memory
so for example if the child gets told
off at the age of two it's likely to be
in circuitry
then if it wants to avoid being told off
again it will conceal what it does
so if it's eaten a chocolate biscuit
it'll just
try and not get caught okay because the
it it's imp impulse will to be eat the
chocolate biscuit but then it will learn
but if you do you can get caught you get
told off so therefore concealer being
caught so this is impulsive and not
thinking of long-term consequences or
values or because this circuitry just
does impulsive how can i get what i want
and get away with it with the least
emotion and or painful emotion whereas
what happens when we're around two as a
secondary system the human circuits
start to develop so these run from the
top of our head almost like a vertical
one down into the center of the brain
and this part the dos lateral prefrontal
cortex we have control of this is our
active thinking conscious awareness of
things like future time so we look at
consequence if i steal the biscuit
what will happen is there an alternative
and now our values start to come into
play it's not the right thing to do
whereas the chimp bin doesn't work with
values
it has values but they're not our values
so we then start having this battle in
our heads
but that circuit doesn't come into a
two-year-old approximately so that's why
we don't have memory before too because
he's not actually functioning and it
starts factual memory rather than
emotional memory
so when you say one in form to chimp the
chimp has got all this intuition and
intuition is previous experience of what
happens
so as he's going to take the chocolate
biscuit
the chimp's brain will remind it this
may not be a good thing it's pleasurable
but it may not be good so that generally
the child now feels on edge
they know what they want to do but
they're on edge and they don't know why
they're on edge
until they have to think it through and
then the chip will remind them you're
getting this feeling because you could
get caught
so the way that system works it gives
you a feeling
you interpret the feeling and then you
make a decision but it's based on
feelings
what was the prehistoric
use case for the chimp well the chimp
brain i mean i i use that because when i
looked
30 years ago i looked at the human brain
and then compared it to the hominids and
spoke to specialists in the hominid
group who were saying that the
chimpanzees brain is is almost the same
as ours and these particular circuits so
that's why we find them entertaining
because they demonstrate what we do yeah
you know and and they will be devious
and they will be quite violent they're
also compassionate but they're all
impulsive and not thought through well
and when i looked at that with the other
great apes so the orangutang the bonobo
the gorilla they didn't actually have
the same circuitry as the chimp
and i couldn't wait for the research i
jumped the gun a bit and called it the
chimp paradox because in the last two
three years it's been published now to
show that the chimp brain in our brain
is closer than we thought
in the way that we think with that
particular circuitry
so that's why i picked the chimp but
it's seen in all animals and it's it's a
defense mechanism to protect you so
obviously eating the biscuits a good
survival mechanism the fact you might
get caught is incidental you hope you
don't but you have to eat so these
circuits are based to
help us to survive so they give us all
our drives but they also give us
experience of what happens when we act
in a certain way and if it doesn't work
we change our reaction right
and you said drives there that was the
second point that i was intrigued by is
how one goes about understanding their
drives i think
um when i in the world we live in
especially you know the social media
world it feels like our drives and our
values are somewhat um sometimes handed
to us and we don't even know that
something isn't our true sort of
intrinsic driver or values but because
of i don't know a desire to be to fit in
or to be to gain approval from people we
take it up as a value of our own or or
we say if we're asked that that's
something that drives us but it's not so
we might say we want to be we want a
lamborghini or we want to be a public
speaker or whatever but really probably
underpinning that is our desire to be um
to get recognition and to to be loved i
don't know um but how do you go about
understanding what your true
drivers are in life and not the things
that you say just uh
yeah this is where when i looked at this
as i said a long time back you start to
see that if you
ask people which is what i do to put
away everything and just get a blank
piece of paper that's why i start my
starting point is always write down the
perfect person you want to be
because this now excludes any of the
drives and a lot of what you're talking
about is actually behaviors attached to
drives they're not true drives drives
are things like the need to eat the need
to have security
these are drives the need to be apparent
and we have these compulsive
driving forces within us that get us out
of our seat and make us find something
whereas gaining approval from people is
actually based in the orbit of frontal
cortex the chimp again where it's
terrified have been excluded from the
troops so a chimpanzee in the wild must
be part of a troop otherwise the
leopard's waiting so lots of eyes
protect you so the chimpanzee has an
inbuilt need to be with other chimps and
in order to do that it must prove to the
other chimps that it's worthy because if
it isn't they could exclude it which
would be death so we we carry that drive
still that we need to be approved the
problem is
the chimpanzee's got it right we've got
it wrong the chimpanzee recognizes it
anyone only wants approval from its
immediate troop whereas we actually try
and get approval from the whole world
you know so one person on social media
tells the world that they're not like us
and we can potentially fall apart
instead of saying actually they're not
in my troops it's not important
so it's important this is an example of
how giving insights people can start
recognizing actually find your own troop
because that's what you need to focus on
not the rest of the world you'll never
please them
you know you're not part of that
so
drives you have to look at and we have i
go through the list of this and then we
say to you for example how strong is
your troop drive we all have one that's
the need to belong to a group of people
or maybe just to one person
but generally we like to have a number
of people around us so it's looking and
saying how strong is that drive now you
full thing and fulfilling it correctly
and and also when you've got your what
i'm calling the troop of people around
you are you actually looking after the
troop and maintaining it and using it
appropriately
makes a lot of sense i've sat here with
a lot of guests and some of them have
tens of millions of subscribers and
followers online
and they still
remarkably they still
um pretty much i'd say 95 percent of
occasions
can have their day ruined by one comment
on a youtube video or an instagram per
post and it does it does like
it does sort of blow my mind a little
bit that
um
such a big tribe and still won yeah i
get that but if you think that um we
society we're told basically to respect
everyone which is correct from our human
brain our chimps are actually saying
just close in and get the people around
you that matter
and please them and look at their
approval and that's what our friends do
they'll be critical but it's it's very
constructive and done with love so we
accept criticism from friends we know
they're on side but if you start
expanding that inappropriately to the
whole world then you're going to stress
your chin to pieces because what you're
saying is i think it's really important
that that person approves of me as well
so again i look at the reality of life
and say let's just get in your factual
memory
some real truths of life and people may
disagree but i ask them what do you
believe because truths are relative to
us so one of the things we know is and
and give this statistic as a loose
statistic
eighty percent of people approve of us
twenty percent love us
sixty percent just to prove
and twenty percent are just not pleasant
people and if we go around believing
that we're really going to make them
into pleasant people or we're really
going to
please them you're going to lose so you
have to step back and get that fact
and then you don't worry if 20 of the
people don't like you or make critical
remarks you just dismiss it and look at
the 20 who do love you who are going to
give you constructive criticism
and respect you so again it's that
learning that your drive is out of
control
you're allowing your drive for the troop
to extend to the world and that's not
appropriate it never was meant to do
that so it's an inappropriate use of
this primitive drive we have
so take me through that that process
then so i get a blank piece of paper i
write down who i want to be yeah um i
would say things like i want to be
and correct me where i'm that's
something wrong here okay because i
won't be wrong
but if i say i want to be
um
i want to achieve great things is that a
drive no that's not a drive that's
something you hope for yeah okay so we
get the terminology right because if you
hope for that but i accept it may not
happen that you know you working with
the human circuit which is logical and
rational so we hope to get like i work
with elite athletes which is privileged
and they hope to get an olympic medal
and
they hope for that they accept you may
not get this even if you're on form on
the day some of you may be better or you
may make an error so as long as you have
that then it shouldn't be stressing you
okay it'll be okay but if you move into
saying i have to get an olympic medal
we're now moving into the chimp circus
yeah because that's not true yeah you
don't have to you know you don't have to
you know but if somebody absolutely says
to me you don't get it if i don't get
then life's not worth living
i'm not going to argue what i'm saying
is that's the choice you're making you
must also accept the consequence
so i i can't put i can't change that
so so when you start your list what i'm
really asking for is you what are your
character traits
so so discipline yeah i mean again i
would test the water because i don't
know what you're going to say here here
in the spotlight
i'll just do a quick one for you
do would you like to be a really nice
good person or would you like to be
successful you're going to be one of
them which would you prefer um a really
nice good person right so i know where i
stand with you now so we have to now
make sure that you understand that's the
prime reason that we're going to do the
work is to get you to be the person that
you want to be
this is the good news
if you write on a piece of paper the
perfect person you want to be so give me
some more character traits
all the things that come to mind are the
impact i want to have on those that
encounter me
so right so you you want to be
inspirational yeah yeah i guess that is
but also just like um
empathetic and compassionate okay
brilliant force you want to be an
empathic guy a compassionate guy
inspirational you're probably going to
add if we go through it's not time
honesty integrity trustworthy you know
respectful
when you've done all this this is really
crucial and it is a light bulb moment
if you think about this that if you had
control of that part of your brain which
you have and there was no interference
from the rest of the brain then that's
exactly how you would be in life true
that is you so what i'm saying is the
reality is fantastic that is you it's
not all you hope to be it is you
it's not
a myth it's neuroscience it's you what
we're now saying is
that doesn't present to the world
because now your chimp and the computer
system the backup to both human and
chimp
now impose
other things and so the world might see
something different so you say to me i
want to be compassionate
and i walk in and say i had a really
long journey today all went wrong and
you're busy and you just get irritated
and say oh for goodness sake stop
morning
and then afterwards you think well that
wasn't very compassionate so i'm not
compassionate but that's that's
misunderstanding the neuroscience you
were always compassionate because your
intention was always to say sorry steve
that you've had a rough journey you know
because i was important otherwise i
wouldn't be telling you i mean you still
might want to say stop mourning after a
while but it's done nicely but what
happened is your chimp is saying i don't
need to deal with this it's doing my
head in so i'll just have a go and
that'll stop him and there you see this
immediate reaction without thought of
consequence so then our paul fails a bit
because i think not nice guy this
but actually when i understand the
science i think he's probably a nice guy
his chimp wasn't very good there yeah
that's very different to you going away
at the end of the day thinking what's
wrong with me why was i lacking in
compassion the answer was get the
neuroscience right you've never moved
position you're always a compassionate
guy who's trustworthy and honest and so
on your chimp has interfered now it's
very critical i expand on two points
here because the listeners are going to
go up
hang on
if this is not an excuse model
100 i'm tough on people
it's not an excuse model your 100
responsible for managing the chimp so
you need an apology
so when you know the chimp's been a bit
brisk or rude you've got to stop and say
i apologize you are responsible so i'm
not saying blame everything on your
chimp i'm not saying that
and the second point is you gave me an
answer there by saying i want to be this
compassionate guy and people say surely
everyone writes the same list absolutely
not in the 90s when i started to really
pull this together and was looking at
the new science
clear as you probably know worked in the
fields of forensics and if you take a
typical person so we'll take you as a
typical person and we say what would you
give you gave me the right list peaceful
calm you'd go through integrity honesty
compassion that is really common on the
list however
when you get to the psychopath
they wouldn't put these and when i asked
them they did not put honesty they did
not put compassion they were not
relevant
they had a very different list of who
they would ideally like to be
and it wasn't pleasant
it was all about power it was all about
ego
these are what are in critical this what
i'm going to be so actually the human in
that person is not the good guy i used
to say it's often the chimp in them
that's the nice guy the actual humans
not so nice at all so it isn't a good
guy bad guy that is not at all what the
model is it's saying we all have these
systems let's find out who we are what
kind of chimp we've got because they're
spread and characteristic and then what
have we got on our computer
i know this is really heavy going no
it's not i hope this is no it makes
perfect sense it's my brain is spiraling
off into loads of different examples
whether that is true and the one of the
first ones that came to mind was about
like leadership and in the in the
business world and i was thinking about
the likes of steve jobs and you hear
about these leaders that are maybe they
appear to be led more by their chimp
because they are incredibly short all
the time they are uh they seem to be
incredibly emotional however when you
reflect on what they've achieved in
their careers they also like even you
know sir alex ferguson's maybe an
interesting example they appear to be um
either using the chimp as a
intentionally yeah or out of control
yeah i mean again
there's nothing wrong with the chimp
people said to me um oh you you'd paint
this picture of this like terrible being
in our heads and i've never said this
and when i wrote the chimp paradox it's
in the title
i said it's your best friend
you know my chimp is my best friend that
doesn't always agree with him and i
always say to people i see him as this
inept best friend who doesn't do the
best things for me at times but he means
well so i know this part of my brain is
a hundred percent on side it just
operates in a way that maybe i don't
agree with at times
but it does i learn to communicate with
it so that i can get it on side and
harness its power so the chimp is the
part of the brain it gives a sense of
humor the human doesn't possess that
it's the chimp that recognizes anomalies
and makes us laugh
it's the chimp that has intuition we
haven't got that the chimp reads body
language we haven't got that so human
circuits fail so this complementary
circuit when it works together we know
even if you go to the corporate world
that business decisions that are made
with logic and emotion are the best
decisions and that's emphasizing
neuroscience that we know decision
making by both human and chimp circuits
together are the best decisions
so you use your chimps intuition and its
enthusiasm and its drives but you
harness them and you channel them so you
learn which is what this is all about
mind management so you start saying i've
got this amazing machine now but it's
almost like a living machine i'm going
to get it on side and help so i agree
with these people that chimps will drive
them to be successful i'd like to think
that my chimp's really very very strong
um but it's on board because i manage it
and it knows i i'm not against my
emotions and my more in my emotionally
based brain i'm not against them i use
them i i think what's the message
they're telling me
so any any emotions we get are messages
they're not meant to be engaged with
they're meant to be worked on so that
you actually use them
quick one i talked to you guys about
huel a lot so i'm going to do a quick
intermission to tell you about a bit of
a change that's happened in the last two
months in my life as you guys know my
favorite heel product historically has
been the ready to drink which is these
bottles here they are nutritionally
complete however recently since huel
introduced the heel protein this now
plays a huge role in my diet the salted
caramel flavor protein from hule which
is only 105 calories and has 26 vitamins
and minerals and 20 grams of protein um
serves two roles in my life now first
thing i do when i wake up in the morning
is i have a glass and then at night time
after i've been to the gym straight
after the gym i have a glass it tastes
amazing if you're gonna try it follow my
instructions here get a couple of cubes
of ice put it in a blender put on the
salted caramel protein and it tastes
like a delicious smoothie i've already
gone through one tub of this i'm
actually on my second tub and i've got
two more tubs to go before i'm gonna
reorder more but genuinely the salted
caramel flavor maybe because i have a
liking for salted caramel for me has
been a game changer
i wanted to talk about exactly that
topic which is like managing your
emotional reactions
across different facets of life and i
think um
i'll go let me just give you an example
of a situation that i went through that
i've read about in my book so
i'm just gonna be completely honest
because that's what i tend to do on this
podcast um i broke up with a girl and um
like two days later i found out that
she'd slept with somebody else and when
i even though i'd broken up with her
when i when i read the message that
she'd slept with somebody else
my brain yeah
revenge
message her to destroy her life
that's what my brain said to me but i
um and
and i'm at a place in my life where i
feel quite
secure in my self-image let's say i
don't feel particularly insecure i'm i'm
i'm a confident person but even i
couldn't seem to get a grip of my own
um
desire to react emotionally in that
situation
um and really interestingly as well it
was actually my friend calling me i went
to the gym i thought maybe i'll go to
the gym and that'll like clear my head
it was my friend calling me and this i
don't know where this fits in psychiatry
but my friend said to me steve just
remember you broke up with her she's
probably doing this to um make herself
feel better and to you know rebound or
whatever
but um that was one of those key moments
where i was like god like
the damage you can do if you don't know
how to control
that like primitive urge to just bruh
okay you've covered a lot of ground yeah
that could be an hour's working so i'm
gonna take it back and try and go very
steadily to try and drive home there's a
lot of areas one is first of all
what would you expect somebody's mind to
do
confronted with the same situation what
would you expect them to do
probably the same exactly so nothing
abnormal happened there wasn't a problem
yeah you're saying this is absolutely
healthy and normal but maybe not helpful
yeah and what you really said because
you've told me this if it wasn't a
problem to you you wouldn't have
mentioned it so clearly your human brain
is saying i don't want to get revenge
that's not what i want what i want is to
just be calm and collected accept the
reality of it and move on
unfortunately we have to learn now how
the mind works
so it's like saying you went to the gym
so therefore you're a fitness man if i
said to you right i've never been to a
gym for 30 years i'm going to go tonight
and at the end of the day i'm going to
be super fit
and you laugh because that's ridiculous
it's not the way the body works so we
have to now look at another aspect so
now we know it's normal how does the
mind work when we get a really nasty
shock and something which is devastating
so the the reason that chimp is there
and the reason we're here
is for us to be safe and present the
next generation to the world that's what
the chimps agenda is so what happened
there is the generation that you thought
you were going to get was taken away
from you so this is devastating so we
expect you to be devastated
we also expect you to accept the mind is
going to now grieve and it will take
approximately three months give or take
you're talking about heartbreak here
yeah you've got to grieve yeah so the
mind has a rule on the way it deals and
processes grief i can't speed that up
so if some like if i meet you that night
and i say right i'm going to get you out
of it i'm going to fail because you have
to go through these ripples and and work
it through so your human brain can do it
in seconds because that's logic she's
gone she was dishonest it's a good thing
she's gone now no more wasted time yep
that's easy but the emotional chimp
brain has got to process it it cannot do
it overnight so you've got to now allow
around a 12-week process and you're
going to go through various stages
of grief in the loss of what is a very
significant relationship and on top of
that there was another insult it wasn't
just she said it's not for me she slept
with someone else so that is really
going to get your chimp you know we
expect it now to be devastated and your
chimps reaction some people wouldn't
but it's common that it wants revenge
it wants to say right if you did this to
me you're going to suffer now
in reality what you've just said by your
nodding is that's not what i want i just
want to move on and accept it wasn't for
me she did what she did that's her
problem not yours
and what your friend did is start to try
and turn it around with some facts to
calm your chimp down and say because it
always looks to the computer let's look
at reality and the reality is if i said
to you um this girl is going to come
back into your life and they'll bring
all that pleasure you used to have but
she's going to have affairs every few
weeks is that what you want no no so you
did break it up
yeah
yeah you know so you just try and look
at it in a different way and say let's
look at the reality and the facts of the
situation but you cannot stop the
grieving you can't stop the yearning or
the bargaining because guys in the
opposition often go back and plead and
then she'll say i made a mistake and and
then you have to make a decision
you know and then they'll bargain again
and then if you go through that you're
going to disorganize stage
but this can all be circumvented if you
suddenly met somebody new your chimp
might recover very quickly is that what
tends to happen well unless we know this
is the rebound right so this is never a
good thing okay i'm sure some of you
listen to going i married the person i
met on the rebound so of course it's all
probabilities but generally speaking you
need time to get over this gather
yourself so you're in a good place when
you do meet somebody else to have a good
relationship
that's interesting so it's quite complex
the whole thing so yes rationally we can
pull you along but we gotta give you a
lot of tlc and that should go through
grieving don't be harsh on yourself and
what your experiences are totally
natural unhelpful but natural so many
people are going through a grieving
process in it could be a significant
life event it could be the loss of a
partner at the death order is there
anything in psychiatry from your
experience that can
okay that process is unavoidable but is
there anything that i can do to help
that process be easier
yes there is i mean one is understanding
it as you say if you start to go through
this and say to people like this is how
your mind has to do this
and like you tell me in the gym you
laugh i can't do it in the night well
how long and you still it's a bit of a
piece of string but roughly speaking if
you keep going regularly two three times
a week maybe three months six months
you're gonna see a difference for sure
and it's the same with me explaining the
mind i would explain to people that we
go through a grieving process you are
likely to experience the following
emotions or stages in the grief process
but you are unique and everybody grieves
individually so it's very important as i
said earlier i don't have a process uh
you know like a recipe and say this is
what we're going to do i work with you
as you grieve but i want you to get
insights that's the key so the work i do
is giving understanding and insight and
then applying this so you learn the
skill of managing your emotions and the
skill of understanding the skill of mind
management that's what i'm about
teaching a skill base so you can be
independent of me but use me as a
fallback
on that on the point of rejection which
we talked about a second ago is it the
stories that i then tell myself about
myself which impact my self-image that
really hold that hurt me the most
because it feels like when you go
through emotional sorry romantic
rejection or heartbreak it feels like
um even if you it's not the sort of like
front of your mind
the fact that someone didn't want you or
they were they wanted someone else
makes yourself tell yourself that you
are not good enough not pretty enough
not smart enough you you weren't enough
and it feels like so much of the hurt
and the pain lives inside that story
you're telling yourself about yourself
and again if you stop and we'd look at
what you've said there are these factual
statements or are there impressions and
feelings impressions and feelings so we
know that the chimp brain is in full
flow now yeah so what we're saying is
don't quench that it's not wrong
it's expressing and it's like as i said
here you've got this best friend so if
this happens to me i now said what is it
you're telling me and you'll go through
all this you know it's the end of the
world and you know clearly no one's ever
going to love you and and then we sort
of counter it by saying well let's look
at that so we start to rationalize and
that can help the grieving process
because we start saying well let's not
just sit there with these falsehoods
let's challenge them and let's replace
them with truths not brainwash it's no
good saying for example say i'm your
best mate and you've just fallen apart
and you say it's because i'm ugly it's
no good me said no you're really
handsome that's not
that's an impression again from me what
what i'd be saying is let's look at
facts if we look at people in
relationships do people find a partner
eventually and the answer is most people
yes so the chances are very high and if
you can get through this
will you eventually get back on your
feet is there a future yeah yeah there
always is a future there always is a
future even for people in a much more
serious situation where they become uh
suicidal um and obviously as part of my
work
you can tell them with honesty there is
always a future and things do change and
feelings do move so when you start
giving these facts and rationalizing the
facts of the situation that is going to
be powerful for starting to settle your
emotions
but giving falsehoods
you know i know you can do it or yo
that's not going to certainly trip the
street wise yeah yeah so he'll just keep
agitating whereas if we talk facts then
it'll settle but again there's a key
point here
we have to find the facts that resonate
with you as facts
because if i said like i just did will
you find another partner what's what's
the general rule if you said to me yeah
but i don't believe that everybody does
there's no point me forcing this truth
onto you i'd have to look for others
that might resonate with you yeah such
as if i go out and actually start
socializing when i'm ready then the
chances are i'll increase my probability
so that gives me a bit of hope you might
work with that yeah
so you've got to find what resonates
with the person
and again that's why i don't have this
recipe i'm saying discover them but
think around but you can offer common
things yeah
super interesting and it again it
perfectly explains why in that moment
for some bizarre reason my friend
telling me being very sort of rational
with me things that i genuinely did
accept to be true
just completely diffused my brain
because he's acting effective as you're
human yeah that's what he's doing he's
coming in rationally and stepping back
and saying let's look at the facts here
yeah and he's hit some nails on the head
where you think oh that's settled me
down a bit yeah so but what tends to
happen is you tend to isolate yourself
most people do this after this has
happened and they go within themselves
and they engage these emotions which
generates more and more falsehoods and
distorted ways of perceiving themselves
and the world
instead of being able to which is not
easy talk to themselves rationally
and preempting things like you know
let's work with reality it's not easy to
do that so when you can't do it it's not
a failure you turn to your best friends
and they'll do it for you
that's so interesting because i just i
just realized um
something that i've started doing in the
last year and people i think are my
proper i'm a little bit strange for
doing this but in those moments
specifically as it relates to like
romantic situations where i'm struggling
to get a to respond or act or behave in
a way which i want to which is in line
with who i want to be
i've got this habit now two things i
mean just correct yeah sure yeah please
who you are who i am not who you want to
be yeah that's so important because you
know if you get that it's a light bulb
moment to say you know you are this
really great individual and it's not
just blowing small cup people people by
and large 90 of people are great people
their chimps
because they're not managed can create
havoc or the computers can have beliefs
in which caused them to act in ways
which are not helpful so they're the
gremlins i talk about so when you look
at that i'm saying you're always this
great person the world may never see it
and my job is to help you to present
yourself as you are to the world then
they will see who the real you is but
that doesn't stop you seeing the real
you
you know when you get home at night look
in the mirror don't see your chimp
looking back
you know
look at look and see the human in you're
looking back the real you and respect
that
because that's who you are so i've
interrupted you no but please thank you
for doing that because it's important
and i i realize that even the slightest
like misuse of words can send you down a
different path exactly so i'm i'm very
keen on making sure my terminology is
right as i describe myself and others um
so if you see me doing that please do
correct um i i again i write about that
in my own book about how just like the
the misuse of like one or two words can
completely send you down the wrong wrong
sort of train of thinking yeah but um
what i'm saying is there's two things
that i've started to do the first is i
now write in the notes of my phone
um
statements i know to be true yeah and
the second thing is this is the slightly
strange thing is i will
have a conversation out loud when i'm
alone to try and rationalize against how
i'm feeling
brilliant so i'm going to pick these
both up because these are really key
points and this is why it's going to
promote the book now
i was
saying that
i wanted to share this these are common
features that we have and there's lots
of them
and one of the things you said
scientifically really intrigues me so
you mentioned what i call the grade a
hits the truth that resonate with you
put them in your phone look at them and
they stabilize your chimp at any point
so you have great air hits so we we
touched on one for example not
everybody's gonna like you and there are
nasty people in the world i'd like to
add some positives there are some
fantastic people in the world and
there'll always be people who love you
you're never alone you just need to
reach out so those are nice greater hits
if they resonate with you but a very
important one
when we looked at therapies and this has
been researched for the last 50 years we
we're intrigued to know why do they work
and i'm giving you the the model i
introduced uh to try and show the new
science base um but the intriguing bit
was when you speak into the air
effectively it's the chimp brain giving
out its thoughts and feelings
and your humans listening
so it actually rationalizes as you
listen and it's not unusual in business
meetings i've seen it where i've worked
with corporate teams and said just speak
what you think but don't judge them they
let their chimps out and at the end i
say to the person what do you think
about that and they'll laugh and say i
don't agree with any of it because now
i've listened to myself it's crazy yeah
yeah so it's very important that we do
speak out and this is what the best of
therapies are that when we talk we start
to listen to ourself and we start to
understand and process but that's
because our human brain is actually now
taking the lead and listening yeah
because it felt because there's been a
couple of key moments where
just context is i've been in quite a
challenging relationship where um my
partner is going through a journey she
lives in indonesia a long way long long
way away and she's going through her own
journey and sometimes she's not always
communicating with me sometimes she can
be unpredictable sometimes she can kind
of go missing for a couple of days in
terms of like being emotionally vacant
and throughout that journey i've tried
not to
like control manipulate impress myself
have high expectation and just kind of
be yeah and let her do what she needs to
do and obviously
my chimp brain
will always be trying to jump to
conclusions or trying to seek control or
to dominate or to
force the outcome or you know to force
expectations on on her or the situation
and my sort of human brain is um
is wanting to be that compassionate and
pathetic person who is understanding and
isn't trying to force an outcome out of
somebody and so when i have that
struggle
it will be lying in a hotel room
somewhere at night
my brain is going
and then i have to speak out loud
to kind of calm myself again so i have
to state what i know to be true yeah and
i if you look at the notes of my phone
now it's not me just saying this there
are a list of 20 things that i remind
myself of that are like fundamental
truths and they calm me yeah
and that's what i advocate and i like
people to get me five yeah and then we
challenge to make sure they are really
strong um and they apply generically
through life yeah you know and and it
does settle our emotional mind down but
having said that
it's not a panacea it's not like it's
always going to settle sometimes we have
specific experiences which can throw us
and then we have to learn how to manage
these emotions so again when you say
you're in the hotel room and your mind
is spinning
stop the battle and now to express your
mind so say to the chimp exactly what is
it you're trying to tell me what are you
worried about and we have to accept and
it's important that sometimes our
relationships are based on trust
and we have to accept that reality we
cannot know everything about the person
we're with
so
clearly we'll ask questions and we'll
form a relationship get to know them but
the end of the day
any friendship or relationships on trust
and we must accept we will never know
sometimes we'll never know and if our
chimps which are panicky a bit and want
guarantees and then we're going down the
wrong path and we have to tell our chimp
you can't do this
the the biggest thing to follow on to
that is as you've experienced and it
almost universal you get your heart
broken it's extremely painful it can
damage you and it often you lose
confidence in all areas of your life so
it's time to just build back up and give
yourself time
but if you
experience that and you go with the
floor not engage with it you will come
out the other side much better much
stronger and then you come in with the
factual evidence again that people do
recover from broken relationships
people don't know
what the next relationship will be not
everybody is the same
so you start like you're saying giving
all these greater hits to it
i'm someone that tries things and and
that was one of the things that i tried
um because it felt like the right thing
to do when my brain was just losing a
bit of control and it genuinely worked
so i carried on doing it um but it's
good to understand the kind of basis in
psychiatry um can i just follow that
through because i know people listening
and when you um
you said to me you know this my mind
spinning in a hotel room there's another
really big truth i say to people
your chimp cannot cannot deal with
uncertainty it's based on so it's never
going to be happy and your job is to say
look we have to live with uncertainty
you have to tell it that you cannot
guarantee it it's a bit like going with
the elite athlete you cannot guarantee a
gold medal so don't try because you're
just going to stress yourself
you know except it's a throw of the dice
in sport life is a throw of the dice all
we can do is try and alter the
probability wait the dice
but there's a big fact here the chimp
can't deal with some outcomes you can
as adult humans we can deal with
anything
and that's a fact we can put in our
computer which will again for a lot of
people settle down there's nothing you
can't deal with you will deal with it
the chimp believes you can't deal with
it
and it doesn't look beyond whereas i'm
saying look beyond and say whatever
happens in life you look back and think
i did deal with life
and maybe we can deal with it quicker if
we work with a mind and learn how to
expedite things like this and and not
sit with them as problems learn how to
move it forward and be much more
positive
uncertainty
stress
one of the topics um you write about in
your book a path through the jungle but
also i've been quite intrigued by over
the years is the idea of stress i think
it's been painted as a really negative
thing something to be for us to avoid at
all costs
but from what i've um understood that's
not necessarily the truth stress can be
a good and a bad thing yeah
i mean trying to just go the new
resilience again if we look at where
stress comes from
it's a good thing provided we act on it
if you have like gone a big dipper ride
your brain releases a lot of
noradrenaline
and we know this is a good thing you get
a thrill from it but if you keep on
being a stressful situation
noradrenaline stays high and that now
becomes damaging to us
and it's joined by the big one which is
cortisol and there are other negative
hormones and transmitters and so these
when they're held at high levels become
damaging right in short bursts they're
actually healthy because they can wake
us up to saying right you need to act
so we do have resilience hormones coming
in
and they will then give us an
opportunity as long as you recognize it
to say stress is welcome provided i act
to remove it there's something i need to
do whatever's causing me the stress what
tends to happen is people either don't
recognize they're getting stressed and
it becomes chronic
and they've got these
habitual behaviors which are damaging to
them and they don't even recognize them
and then they get symptoms of stress
which they also not recognize because
people think stress is where we're
wringing our hands and panicking and
that's not really true stress comes in
all different forms and often isn't
recognized
so for example
we know things like all your drives may
go out so your eating drive sex drives
sleep drives these all start to falter
can change in any direction but also
things like irritability suddenly
finding got short fuse constantly being
tired this is this is using evidence of
stress somewhere in your life
um but even more subtle ones when you
get people with
really bad anxiety so you have a
generalized anxiety states gross anxiety
they can be appear selfish because
suddenly they become so vulnerable in
their own eyes and stressed they don't
actually pay attention to people around
them and when we treat them and they get
better
they suddenly start engaging with people
again and show demonstrate respect and
come and understanding and
but while they're not well
they become almost selfish or appear
that way so again you can get people who
are stressed and appear to be very
self-interested
and it's really vulnerability they're
under stress and we misunderstand that
or misinterpret it and start thinking
someone's a selfish person i mean they
may be selfish but i'm saying it is one
of the hidden stress factors that can
start appearing
in terms of the causes of stress um
well i think one of the widely held
beliefs is especially now as we think
about mental illness
is that it's a lot of it's about sort of
pent up unaddressed issues
or us not releasing or expressing what
we're thinking or feeling is that
accurate
it is but then the
etiology of the cause of stress is
multiple so again it could be for
example you've got an ongoing problem
somebody bullying you you know that's
stressful or you're lacking a partner
and it really isn't working out and that
can stress you because you feel like
it's never going to happen you know
there's false starts and you start to
become stressed by it or as you said you
could have experiences from way back
which have never really been worked
through or addressed and they therefore
keep surfacing they bubble under these
emotions and that will definitely create
stress
it tends to be they they don't present
with stress as such they present with
odd emotions so they translate into
things like irritability
and and when you say well let's look at
why you're being irritable it's
unaddressed issues that that you need to
get up to the surface in the time you
want to do it
and then clear the computer system as
i'm calling it so you've processed these
issues and sometimes an addiction and
addiction too well so um
my business partner and he's talked
about this very much openly at length
and he's actually come on this podcast
and talked about this he obviously um he
became a
alcoholic yeah um when we were growing
the business
and i i believe in his words because it
was incredibly it was incredibly
difficult we were you know 20 years old
we had you know hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of employees all around the
world and we'd never done this before
and
we were living together and i think the
pressure of the business um and the
stress as he would describe it um
meant that he
he was turning to alcohol to cope
okay so two separate things again is
like i mean i don't know because i'm
just giving like a little potted history
so clearly um
alcohol is a coping strategy a very poor
one
that people use to get social confidence
for example or remove anxiety or even
depression and generally it won't work
out it will end up being a problem
within itself but alcohol disorders that
then in in approximately one in eight
people will change the brain in the way
it functions and they then get these
cravings and addiction
whereas a lot of people it's more a
behavioral addiction so it's a case of
getting new behavior work out what's
causing the problem and we sort it and
they can stop and drink alcohol socially
but we have to accept that genetically
uh some people i'm going to my medical
room here
i worked with alcohol services for some
years and patients who are addicted mean
they actually have a different brain
system so we know that their brain will
cause craving
and they will respond to certain
medications that behaviorally drinking
people won't so again it's learning
which group you're in and they have they
must abstain because we know that if
they drink small amounts of alcohol it
sets the system off again so we get this
repeat behaving we have to say you know
unluckily it's about no different to
someone who can't drink milk if they've
got lactose intolerance the answer is
you can't drink milk um and if they've
got an addictive genetic loading towards
alcohol then they mustn't drink that
we're saying this is just a one-way
street to disaster is that a thing oh
yeah yeah people are genetically
predisposed so we know it runs in
families and we know that
people's brains react differently to
alcohol intake and there is a subgroup
where we're changing the way that they
operate in the brain so therefore we
know that as i said they will get that
craving i mean there was once a group of
guys in london early days when my career
in the alcohol services and these are
all guys who had problems with alcohol
and asked them i said look i've got the
medical knowledge and but you tell me
the reality is what makes you think
you're an alcoholic and they said
something interesting which rang true
with the neuroscience later in my career
they said
we know we're alcoholics because if we
go to a pub and we ask for a drink it
won't stop yeah whereas people who are
drinking for other reasons can stop
whereas we immediately change wandering
and we change yeah and that was such a
fantastic thing to get from these guys
i'm indebted to them because it was
almost a question i'd ask and it seems
to run through yeah nearly every case i
know now we've got a problem
whereas if people say no i could stop
and i don't you know
bite my nails when i leave i just think
okay have one today but someone has got
a true
addiction a physical addiction they said
their mind changes after one drink it's
just completely different and you can't
stop the craving appears i i am i've
been saying um when i talk about my
business partner dom and he doesn't mind
me talking about because he's been as i
said he's been on this podcast but he's
very very open and he's a big he's a big
public speaker about the topic of
alcohol and sobriety but um the way i
would describe my experience with him
and my other friends is just as a graph
so dom's drinking if he had and i'd say
this i've said this multiple times if he
had one
the graph would look the line of the
graph would look like this
mine would be
i could have three and then stop yeah so
his was always like this so if he if he
went to the bar i knew the end of the
night would be
him falling over because there wouldn't
be the thing in his brain
he can't stop
and whereas i can have two and i'm like
oh that's me done or i don't need any
more or you know i'm whatever and that's
well interesting when i started looking
at this and we've detailed a bit the
neuroscience behind it brought me back
to the chimp model because we know that
we make decisions from either the chimp
system or the human and when we drink
alcohol it actually interferes with the
circuits of rationality
so the human effectively gets disabled
so now our chimp is fully in charge that
does impulsive things which the next day
it may very well regret and that's
because at the time the decision making
they've got is impaired
so and
you know most people say oh i'm better
for a drink it's interesting that most
partners say no they're not
they're not so we the brain actually
fools itself
so so there is a biological basis behind
the
decision-making we get when these people
have got addictive
uh genetic personalities so that they
actually can't stop
i'm conscious of um people thinking that
you know because we'll all know a friend
like that yeah but it doesn't
necessarily mean they're an alcoholic
does it no i mean i don't i don't
personally like the term i think we just
look at you know the fact that they're
addicted to a substance of some kind or
they've got a craving i'd much rather
give that terminology otherwise it feels
a bit judgmental so i'm just saying you
know how do you use alcohol do you
misuse it or do you use it appropriately
where do you fall and if you've got an
addiction to it then let's look at that
addiction and see whether it's a
physical addiction or psychological
addiction so again it's like going
through a grid to make sure we get the
right thing for the right person
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast one of the
brands that make that transition much
much easier they are at the forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology
and their products are really really
changing the game if you're on youtube
you can see what i'm holding in my hand
this is called the eddie right it's the
uk's number one solar powered diverter
so what is a solar diverter it's a
device for people like you and me that
means you can divert your excess energy
back into your home rather than back
into the grid which will save you power
and money it's super user friendly and
easy to install and you can control it
using the my energy app on your phone to
find out more about this product and
more products like here that will help
you make that sustainable transition
head over to myenergy.com and um i
highly recommend you check out the eddie
it's um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
one of the things you talk about
extensively is about forming habits
and um
a lot of people in my life recently
including myself have tried to be tried
to form habits especially during the
lockdown when so much of our lives was
um our habits were broken our cycles
were broken because we were all trapped
in our houses so whether we you know had
formed a habit of going to the starbucks
then the gym in the morning or whatever
we had our habits broken so i spent a
lot of time thinking about how i could
form healthier habits in my life one of
them was working out every day um but i
and one of the sort of i guess popular
narratives is that if you do something
for 21 days it becomes a habit
what is the truth about habits and how
we form them
i mean there's a lot of research on this
and they're a little bit contradictory
so read and believe what you like but i
mean the general fail is that if you
look at why we form a habit
it's either consciously done with the
belief system under or it's
unconsciously done
we aren't thinking about it a common one
for example a poor habit is
and i use this a lot when i do keynote
speeches to say to people when you go
home if you're with a partner that you
love um how do you present to them when
you arrive
and it's amazing how most people mourn
which you know they've not thought that
what they don't want to see somebody
morning you don't meet someone and say
you could have this every day of your
life i'll come back
you know so what you do is you walk in
and think what habit would you like and
the belief then is if i go in morning
they could leave me yeah this could
damage now that's going to shift your
habit so once you've turned the belief
around this you're unconsciously doing
it without thinking this is damaging
and so if you actually sit down and work
that out and put in your computer system
then when the chimp gets through the
door it's not going to mourn because
what the chimp has to do scientifically
is consult the computer before it does
anything it all happens in a tiny
fraction of a second but if the
computer's programmed to say don't
forget
it will unconsciously remind the chimp
you need to be in a good place when you
walk in because that's what they're
going to decide on whether they're there
the next night
so you start to re recognize that
being someone who moans all the time or
complains when you first meet someone
isn't ideal so we have these unconscious
habits which we're not aware of which we
can bring to conscious by start to look
at our life and say is this how we want
to be but you have to ask the question
oh we have habits like we eat too much
now these are different because the
first one wasn't based on a drive it's
just based on a
behavior that we've got into a pattern
that the eating habit's much more
complex because now you've got not only
a behavior that we've got into like
eating too much or eating the wrong
things
we're driven with an incredibly powerful
survival drive to eat
so now we've we have to deal with two
aspects one is what is it the habit that
we want to get and what are the beliefs
we're going to underpin with it and how
we're going to manage this drive
how we're going to fulfill the drive in
a way that our chimp's happy
that it's got its drive fulfilled and
we're happy
so now you really have to look at that
so that's a big battle that's not an
easy battle but it can be one it can be
one
so again habits are not straightforward
they need to be subdivided and say let's
look at unconscious conscious whether
they're linked to drives or they're
linked to some really bad experience
sometimes we have a habit because we've
got a bad experience it's like you
explained that you went through a really
bad time with this girl if it got
repeated god forbid if it got repeated
three or four times you can see how your
habit would be to distrust and it would
become a habit because your belief is
that
these women aren't trustworthy and
suddenly generalizes all women are like
this and you hear guys saying this and
clearly that's a song true you know and
so with you i'd be looking and saying
when you meet this what are you looking
for in the girl are you looking at
physical looks are you looking at do
they make me laugh or are you looking at
the values
so we can actually start looking at how
are you choosing your partners
and that might help you to avoid
the behavior the habit of picking up
what you might then define as the wrong
person and and worse even to blame
yourself then instead of saying right
let's analyze this so again there's
habits there where it's based on your
belief of what you've experienced or
you're letting your chimp make decisions
instead of your human saying hang on can
i make decisions from a more rational
basis than just keep deciding on an
emotional basis there's a lot of
reflective work that goes into being
able to understand and kind of rewrite
those
first like spot to understand and
rewrite those um
those those beliefs you have
what what is what is the path to what is
the path to reflection for you know not
everybody can go and see
yourself every day yeah i mean
i'm going to be mentioning the vote now
not trying to promote but
um
obviously i help i've helped a lot of
people it's been a massive privilege
it's very humbling when people do do
well but one of the complaints people
said is exactly what you said i can't
work with everybody and i've got a team
so we'd run lots of stuff workshops and
one-to-ones however
for joe public some said i want to work
on my own and so i wrote this
path with the junglers as a manual
with lots of diagrams lots of science
references this time for people who want
to follow them up um i hope it's really
readable and it starts from square one
and says let's look at the structure and
function in mind then it takes you
through this a journey almost through
the mind saying let's look at how
emotions work we talk about grief
processes and relationships um talking
about interacting with others so i've
done a lot and basically what it leads
to is
eventually you learn how to become
robust and resilient in other words get
yourself into a great place uh and and
this takes you with practical exercises
that you try out and find the ones that
resonate with you across eight stages
yes understanding your mind emotional
management working with emotions
changing habits and managing life events
the two main stability stabilizers of
the mind creating a stress-free
lifestyle optimizing interactions with
others and then stage eight is pulling
it all together
one of the um the last thing i really
wanted to to talk to you about was this
um this idea of um fear of failure which
i think underpins so much of
specifically for my audience um one of
the big barriers in their life they're
i i get thousands of messages every week
and it's people trying to take that step
to to become to start their business or
to you know start that hobby or pursue
that dream they have but there seems to
be something holding them back okay
i mean i'll just take what you've given
me there because it could be a multitude
of reasons as i keep saying everyone is
unique and that's that's what's
intriguing about working with people
it's fantastic because every person is
different
but you mention a fear of failure so i'm
going to be controversial i don't
there's no such thing in my book as a
fear of failure what we're really saying
and it's really important subtlety as
you said before about language
your fear isn't failure it's fear of not
being able to deal with the consequences
of failure
now that might sound the same thing but
it isn't because if you fear failure
there's nothing you can do with that
because it's it could happen
so you're stuck with fearing failure
whereas if you say i feel the
consequences
of failure not been able to deal with
them
now you can do something because we can
look at the consequences and address
them and get people to be able to say i
can deal with it whatever happens i can
deal with it so the fear of
not actually succeeding disappears
because they've got this i'm aware i've
got a plan
so i meet a lot of people who say that
to me particularly athletes i fear
failure and i have to correct it and say
that's not actually what the brain is
looking at it's saying i fear not being
able to deal with the consequences of
failure and that's something i can work
with
there's just two other things before we
round up that i was really intrigued by
um and we might might have touched on
both in various ways throughout this
conversation this idea that if you wake
up in the morning and you set your state
just by saying to yourself i'm going to
have a good day increases the chance of
you having a good day yeah is that
well again i'm not into brainwashing but
there is some truth in the sense that
what you're really saying if you stop
and i do advocate people sit on the end
of the bed when they get up and say
let's just reset and get some
perspective before i begin my day i do
advocate this strongly
because what you're doing is you're
actually saying to your computer system
this day is going to be good so you've
added a lot of underwritten beliefs now
which are things like
i'm going to make the most of it i have
no intention of dwelling on misery i've
no intention of being negative there's
lots of things you've said in that one
statement potentially and you've primed
your computer with that so when you go
downstairs then and you get a letter on
the doorstep that's got a bill
your chimp will immediately go to react
but it has to look to the computer and
if you've already said it's going to be
a good day
it will remind the chimp there's no
point in stressing it's going to be a
good day and it can therefore be
scientifically accurate that your chimp
will stop and that gives you human
chance to go it's only a bill
and connected to that my last point is
about gratitude something you talk about
it's well in the power of gratitude
yeah this again the research uh shows
that people who are grateful for things
in the life and again i do promote this
and say let's look at what you've got
and let's look at what's really good
things that have happened to you and
there's so much we're grateful for the
evidence is overwhelming that people who
are grateful throughout life have really
good psychological and physical
good health so it affects the entire
system just by being grateful and seeing
life in a different setting rather than
constantly thinking what i like
look at what you've got you can practice
that and you can practice and that in
itself can become a habit
that can be a habit there's lots of
habits we can do i've offered some in
the book it's amazing and it'll help so
listen this this book is um your first
book was amazing because as you say
introduced the idea and the the sort of
the model yeah but the what i think is
so um
amazing about this book is how sort of
inclusive it is and actionable and as
you said there's pictures there's
diagrams it feels more like
like a workbook you get when you're
trying to um methodically work exactly
what it is and we're using it as a
companion to the eight workshop series
we do which runs through the eight
stages so you're absolutely right so
this is for someone who really takes it
seriously and they can dip in and out
but i'd advise them to to go through it
steadily
and apply maybe some of the themes every
week
because i think that's how we get them
into our life as as permanent habits as
you'd say
um i can't recommend this book enough
because your work has helped so many
people and i i said to you before we
started recording my business partner
was really struggling with um problems
in his life and i said he doesn't read a
ton of books but the book that he did
read was the chimp paradox and he
evangelizes it and credits it with
helping him overcome his alcohol
addiction but really kind of get his
psychological sort of like his yeah
psychological dysfunction in order and
for you to have then gone and created a
book like this that is a methodical work
book i think is really going to have
even more impact on people and i'd
highly recommend anyone listening to
this i'm not just saying this because
he's sat here but um you really are an
author of our time that i think has um
helped to
shine a light on the most important
um thing in the world which is the human
mind
i think that is the center point of all
of our decision-making control influence
love happiness fulfillment and i don't
know a book or someone better to help us
understand it than this book and you so
thank you very much but don't forget
congratulate your colleague because i
can only offer they do the work straight
yeah so he's the one who's managed it
he's the one who needs to pat himself on
the back same with everyone you know i
don't do it i just offer the tools that
you can do you got to pick them up and
do them so then congratulate yourself so
but thank you very much for inviting me
thank you been an absolute pleasure
thank you thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you